Fire Emblem fates it's out almost we
come on tease 19th yeah that dude I
think of last year came out in japan
yeah first of all how many [ __ ] games
is this because like its three-game am
usually doing for this game three
explain to me why it's three games Alexa
well this was Peters okay so well Peter
decided it was gonna be three separate
reviews ok but so it's uh they hired a
television drama writer ashen Kobayashi
to write the story for this game because
people criticized awakening story and
we're like oh it's not that good so this
guy and intelligent systems decided till
I guess go overboard and they made three
separate stories and made it three
separate games and they are three
separate stories with three very
different styles so oh so it's not just
the story they actually played
differently as well they do yeah yeah um
it's I'd say if you look at it from like
a bird's eye view it's like okay that
looks the same yeah but but functionally
sort of you know how you go about your
journey and you know this is a game
where if you play like I am there's
permanent death and so it's really
important that your team is strong and
capable and it's it's tough because my
version conquests that I'm playing
there's no option to grind for
experience or two then build
relationships and then make your party
work better together so I actually don't
have an opportunity to do that so I'm
just grinding like not grinding this not
the right word I'm beating my head
against a wall trying to beat these
missions with my team that's pretty
scrappy Alexa on the other hand has the
opportunity to scout I'm grinding in
both respects okay it was married
everyone has kids like I've got all the
kids everyone's really high-powered like
birthright gives you a lot more
resources and there's the scouting
feature which lets you randomly generate
an endless amount of optional side
quests so you can just go and pound out
a few and either work on someone's
relationship or work on leveling someone
up okay so i've got a extremely large
team think I've like 2044 remedies at
this point I think I'm down to like 16
people or so it's rooted I'm okay what
of it the third one who's reviewing them
what does that play like I'm so I'm
reviewing birthright and revelry okay
okay and revelation
so birthright so the whole I mean
they've marketed this to death but the
whole thing is like you have to make a
choice you were raised by this family
but you find out you're not you're not
part of the nor Kingdom you were born in
hoshido okays go your birth family or
stick with your adopted family right and
birth rate is you go to your birth
family conquest is you stick with your
adoptive okay revelation is join us on
you say no you say I will not fight
either of you okay so neither sides when
you start neither side wants to help you
so you literally have like four units
for like five missions me and my best
friend and my Butler and some other
person like going through whatever and
it's some a little bit of a mix of what
you're telling you about conquests and
birthright like all of my resources are
still available right and I can still
grind however the map layouts are
different like there's a lot more
manipulating of the environment like
you'll have you'll be on floating
islands and have to interact with
portals that will put you all over the
place when maybe your your team is split
and you have to like meet up or you have
to catch an enemy before they escape at
a certain number of turns so it's a sort
of a mix between the two but it's
definitely a little bit more like
birthright in that I have everything I
need and everyone is happy and married
and has kids poor guy I made the mistake
of playing it on classic but I will wait
to describe why that was a mistake for
me personally I can't talk about it too
much the embargo for the reviews next
week okay so but we'll get into some of
your thoughts on well how you're
enjoying it in a little bit we got a
bunch of questions from people so I want
to get to those first questions from
Jacob weisner he asks how do you feel
about the weird ass face padding
mechanic being cut from the Western
release non plus or relieved it's still
there it's still there there are there
are it's still there it's not totally
gone okay face padding so when he was
when you video games when you're in a
you can't do it to everyone I mean you
can do it to everyone who do dennys they
can't do it to everyone when you marry
someone I'm sure it's like implied
consent you can rub their face yeah it's
implied consent did you wash your hands
I'm sorry sounds like pork oh no um but
so you you have like a like a little
like apartment that's yours and you can
invite people in one-on-one to talk to
you when you get married that person is
always there waiting for you when you
come home
sure and as you slave right and as you
as you oh I married my Butler so it's
like really weird um so like the longer
the more times you go in there like
every two missions or so something new
happens in your bond deepens and new
events will occur and one of them is
they're sleeping and you have to take
the three DS stylus and rub their face
until I wake up I actually uh if you Jam
the stylus down and like hit them
they'll wake up and be like blah and
they're like really unhappy with you or
you can be nice to them and then there's
another one where they have just gotten
out of the bap and the prompt is blow
gently and you have to blow into the 3ds
mike its to watch like remove the box
below stealer steam and it just team on
the screen and the steam just goes away
it's like so I'm like sitting like in my
apartment like frantically blowing on my
3ds trying to figure out like huh
whatever so are they more provocative in
the japanese release or something or I I
looked it up and there's a couple of
ones where like if you're like touching
your adopted no you're touching your
biological sibling they'll be like what
would mother think or just like I love
it when you put your hands there oh I
did some research it is there the
darknet the darknet but a lot of that
stuff is slowly thats Sarah oh it comes
out well so there's a there's a thing
where you invite people into your house
to hang out and that's where most of the
petting would have occurred is when they
come to visit it's very obvious right
now what you can do is sort of just like
look at their body while they flirt with
you which is whatever um you can like
scan them from like here okay yeah but
like no feet action now no food no key
though they have feet this time they
didn't have feet before in awakening the
character models had no feet great the
sims constantly on edge pretty much well
I don't necessarily know if I agree that
it was necessary to remove this stuff
yeah Fire Emblem like holes they're
mostly wholesale I can't I can't wrap my
head around getting upset about it
honestly it is so it is such a minor
facet of the game at large um that you
know when people are decrying like
censorship and stuff like that one they
don't understand what censorship is yeah
too it's like what do they get what are
they really getting upset like this
isn't the fight it's like yeah like I
mean there's there's so much more to
this game that is so wonderful and if
that's the one thing you want to get
upset about it to the point that you're
like essentially calling out Nintendo
and call
out this game as Nate like do you're
missing the bigger picture like entirely
um you know I get you want you know
everything that you were expecting right
but like it is it that is it worth
getting that upset about can't we be
happy that we're actually getting this
game and that would look like a fire
down like look where is in North America
Lisa because a lot of people are that
you're right like at least we're getting
it because like folks in Europe are
freaking out thinking they're not
getting it for a long time but but like
but let's celebrate the game because it
is like a wonderful game in many regards
and this one thing that is so
inconsequential to the larger picture
we're gonna get upset about that and
make that the discussion point yeah I
don't get it I got more questions here
Edmund black asks in the private
quarters for a fire emblem faith is
probably what we just talked about
there's mention of additional features
for spouses can you tell us what those
features are um can i maybe some maybe
embargo e it's not story related that's
not story related the games been on
japan for long okay alright so there's
the blowing that i talked about earlier
there's the petting and then if you get
up to a certain level you actually get a
special item that will um that's only
available to you and your spouse that
like reduces the amount of damage you
both take when you're next to each other
in battle right just like actually a
really good to prenuptial agreement yeah
pretty much but it's like a pretty cool
item um the child i finished yeah oh
yeah and then you have well they're not
in the quarters but you can also like
have children and all the children are
actually pretty powerful you can make
the right yes we're send them out they
become units and some of them come out
like fully formed ready to go stats
maxed out your dad gonna meet you very
much and leave her birthday look I have
a I'm playing um in the end of birth
rate I had a child army out on the field
oh my god great work metal gear solid 5
all over again just incredible oh I
guess they're so loved I've got another
question here question trio I don't have
I sorry I don't know who said this but
it's a knife and awakening rather easy
is fates more difficult I mechanically
complex ma I believe request is cuz
birth rate is like of course the
conquest is pretty hard um you know as
always choosing between classic and
casual
can dictate your experience but there
are difficulty settings as well so if
you're looking for a challenge you can
definitely find it I would assume in
both versions if you want to play
lunatic mode go crazy no look I'm able
to deal with someone dying now I mean I
think this game is is pretty hard anyway
on normal especially with classic where
permadeath is a thing and because it's
you know random dice rolls for some of
the percentages for these things it's
easy to find yourself confident and then
cut down by just one guy who like kills
your main character so cool I couldn't
couldn't help it revelations their
relation revelation it's like the matrix
I'm gonna keep saying wrong revelations
revelation that's it in March the other
two are out in February and how are you
enjoying them so far which is like the
one that's kind of do you think is the
best of the three maybe mm I don't think
we're allowed to really get back into it
yeah to clarify revelation will actually
be available on launch day for anyone
who got the special edition oh right
really which opens up a whole other
topic for this game whoa so that means a
special edition has all three versions
on one cartridge stored locally how much
is it 80 bucks but it's totally sold out
there's no way to buy it now lets you go
on ebay and drop it so if you didn't get
that then you basically half the weight
the best parts month yes yeah and then
what you have to do is buy the second
portion of the game as DLC and then by
revelation is dlc as well oh oh so you
can't just get revelation then on its
own you have to buy the second and then
the third part they they do that because
revelry revelations plot is something
that's hinted at in both conquest and
birthright right so like it doesn't I
guess I guess it would make more sense
like I play birthright first and things
make more sense to me but it's like it's
like a they don't want to like spoil
things like a revelation that will
expose pretty much everything I think I
recall in mice my playthrough a let me
give me the option to choose revelation
right away yeah mine okay yeah yeah
exactly yeah they don't recommend it
there's like there's like a thing in the
game that's like spoilers for the other
games how was it launched in japan
though wasn't all launched as one thing
was it was it i think it's a very
similar story with did yeah they divvied
it up or they had one version the head
all it's difficult to meet this from my
perspective it seems kind of weird but
it's difficult for me to pass judgment
because i don't i'm not for many of the
franchise and i don't know the
intricacies of the three different games
does it seem does that seem reasonable
to you or does that seem kind of
weird the special edition thing is kind
of unfair I think like having the early
access to it well I think the fact that
it's so limited in quantity yeah whereas
if anyone wants to do it because look
it's convenient right like who wants to
download all that stuff have all that
space on your SD card when you could
just have it all in one cartridge I
think these each individual game is so
big on its own and the stories are very
different like just talking to Alexa
about one character in her plot like
totally different outcome you know a
totally different place in the world so
it's interesting like on their own like
they're each worthwhile things that I
would say yeah like this is a good full
price game but the fact is is like they
all are like going to be coming out at
the same time they're all available why
divvy it up like that I don't know but
worst of all why limit it to the special
edition Roger all versions yeah last
question I guess are all three videos
going up at the same time they should be
yeah looking at next Wednesday yep yeah
how much time have you put into it so
far um I a lot I I think I'm on our 15
in the second revelation okay now and I
went over 24 hours for the first game
and I did all like the site's the side
stuff I'm like obsessed with marrying
all my characters and getting their kids
because our kids are so powerful it's so
easy look at the Capitol oh no it's
awful I'm like I'm like I'm like in my
house and like my boyfriend's asleep and
I'm in the dark under the covers like
papa just like the Mary Mary everyone go
I don't do him crazy andis from Salt
Lake City he knows all about that all
right so in other reviews with sometime
next week wednesday at seven a.m. that's
why am i think it sometime in the
morning
you